when it's all said and done, I you know,
I'm a practical pragmatic guy and if I'm
going to start veering off and, you
know, conjecturing about history, I want
to know what its value is. Okay? And I
determined after thinking about the
Nommo position is that you have in the
whole world, you got two two people and
just two. You got Muslims and
non-Muslims, right? Everyone fits that.
You're either a Muslim or you're you're
a Christian, a Jew, an atheist,
Buddhist, whatever, Hindu. Okay? the
this argument. Okay. No, Muhammad did
not exist. I readily I've from the very
start, my very first video, I I admit
it's a pmic against Islam. It has merit
in as much as a Muslim believes it. The
only drawback is I don't think it's it's
a strong I don't think it very and I
think he even said that. I think Jay
himself admits this isn't for the
average Muslim because they're not going
to take the time or, you know, just like
your average Christian is not going to
How many Christians I find it funny how
many Christians have been reading books
about Muhammad's not existing and
watching debates and but they don't
they've never read a book about Jesus
not existing. Why is that? I mean, if
you're being sincere, shouldn't you be
more threatened by an attack on Jesus?
But you just ignore it. And that's fine.
I ignore it, too. So, why are you
gravitating towards the Muhammad thing?
Because you're looking for that. this
actually fits your agenda. But okay, so
it it it's one thing to take this
argument to Muslims. All right, I think
that has merit if you can get them to
believe it. What I'm seeing is this is
this argument is being weaponized
against non-Muslims. When I talk about
Muhammad, I think that's actually very
beneficial to people to non-Muslims
because it helps them understand how
Muslims think. It helps them, you know,
see the doctrines and the teachings and
the lifestyle of Muhammad, much of which
is embarrassing to Muslims. Okay. M
Muhammad's life is the Achilles heel of
Islam. Okay? Has always been. So to it's
wonderful for Muslims to know that
non-Muslims don't believe he exists
because now they're not going to look
into his life. They're not going to
criticize him. Okay? And I gave one
example and this happens all the time.
Okay? I'll I'll I'll make a video. I'll
write a whatever a book or an article
and I'll mention Muhammad. Oh my god. As
if he was real. And uh but there's a
good lesson in it. People will actually
learn continuity. how Muhammad thought,
how it still applies, etc. And then
someone has to come crashing in and
screaming, "No, Muhammad didn't exist.
You're crazy. What are you talking
about?" etc. Now, what did this person
contribute to the non-Muslims who are
listening? Okay. All they did is confuse
him. All right? take away knowledge,
intellectual disarmament as I call it,
and kind of also offer a false sense of
relief or assurance because there's no
there's no denying that if you believe
Muhammad never existed, that gives you a
kind of self asssurance as opposed to
believing that guy was real. Okay? Um,
and you can't help but think it's going
to go away eventually. All right? But so
the the no argument amongst non-Muslims,
I see it creating lots of problems. But
what is the good it brings? So let's so
here are the let's say I'm willing to
sacrifice all the difficulties we have
and how we're going to be intellectually
uh disarmed because we don't know about
Muhammad anymore. The Achilles heel of
Islam. So what is the good that I'm
going to gain? Uh nothing. I've you've
convinced me to go from Muhammad was a
false prophet and Muslims are deceived
to Muhammad was a fake prophet made up
and Muslims are deceived. Okay. It's the
same exact thing. you haven't but it
seems like these there are certain
non-Muslims who think this is so
profound they're conflating their belief
with Muslims they think that because
they believe it which and it's no it's a
small shift in their mind I just told
you um either way Muslims are deceived
by a lie whether the lie is Muhammad
himself lied or whether the lie is he
was made up for political reasons and
there's a lie and they're following it
nothing changes so I just find that this
entire argument is so counterproductive
when it's directed against non-Muslims
There's nothing to be gained. It's not
going to help Islam. How I just said it.
Convert every single last Muslim into
this idea that that Muhammad never
existed. What happens? Is Islam going to
disappear? Are Muslims going to be
shocked and they're all going to
re-evaluate their religion? No. You're
they're going to look at you, oh, you
went from being an infidel who doesn't
believe in the da the call. You don't
believe that Muhammad is who he said he
was, uh, the prophet, and now you
believe he doesn't exist. So you're
still the same thing. You're an infidel.
You're a caffer. Nothing changes. So I
hope people start understanding that
this whole thing, it's only merit, if
you want to, if you want to give it any
merit, is when it's directed against
Muslims. All right? But that's not what
I'm seeing. I'm seeing it constantly
spilling over and it's claimed to it's
almost like the nomos have realized that
Muslims aren't listening to this. It's
not affecting them. So they've looked
around to find who's going to give us
ear. And lo and behold, a lot of
non-Muslims, especially Christians, love
to hear this. So, they've gone to them
with this tale and they all jump on it
and they all embrace it, which is fine.
Again, it's your prerogative. But ask
yourself, it's not this isn't he, you
can believe Muhammad didn't exist. That
doesn't affect Islam any way. And I just
told you it's creating a lot of problems
for the rest of the people when you come
crashing in and screaming about Muhammad
didn't exist and you have nothing to
offer in its place except emptiness and
uh ignorance essentially. Whereas the
traditional view of believing him is you
at least will study his life. You'll
understand what he's all about. I just
told you I always for years I've been
watching and a lot of western people
don't know this but um Arabic pmics is
from not from from former Muslims who
became Christians from people like
Zechariah Butrus Abuna Zakariah Butros I
mentioned brother Rashid there's many of
them and it's all in Arabic and these
are the ones that Arab Muslims Arab
speaking Muslims listen to they're not
listening to Jay Smith they're not
listening to me okay because I'm writing
and speaking in English uh and all those
pmics okay are entirely about Muhammad
and his life. Nobody ever says he
doesn't exist. Okay? It's always about
what he said in the hadith, etc., and
what he did in the weaponized against
Muslims to shame them. This is how your
prophet lived. This is what he did. This
is Do you believe this is from God?
Okay, that is that is the powerful thing
that's happening in the Arabic world
that most Westerners have no clue.
That's what they're watching. Millions
and they're fighting and people are
getting killed over this because it's a
language thing obviously. Um, but the
argument they all use is that Muhammad
of course existed. And now we're going
to show you how he was a false prophet.
[Music]